hey guys what's up this is andrew for
transcendences.com so in this video guys
i'm back to make some technical analysis
on tesla we have a lot of things to say
so let's analyze everything that we're
having and let's see what can happen
next let's get into it
[Music]
all right so i'm going to start on the
daily time frame in this video guys i
want to show you some very cool things
so daily time frame sometimes you guys
know that i'm using a log scale
logarithmic scale all right like that
and sometimes i need to switch to
regular scale so let me show you why so
for now i'm gonna go on a regular scale
the reason being that here i can i'm
analyzing the move since since march 20
right even since october 19 but you have
here a trendline guys that has many many
reactions and when a trendline has many
many reactions it means that a lot of
traders are paying attention to it and
that it will have a big impact if it is
broken and here destroy land guys i've
been following the streamline for quite
some weeks and i posted that in my
discord guys that you know this level if
broken it won't be looking good and
look first the number fraction one two
three four five here and here one two
three so eight reactions
nine ten ten reactions so we have
consolidated here guys
as you can see this is a very nice
consolidation guys this is what you need
to be looking for right this okay
look at that guys this is a liquidity
area because look at the volume it's a
very low volume so it's a consolidation
area where you have liquidity just below
okay so one if you go through this kind
of areas it will trigger a strong move
let me show you an example so i'm here
showing you guys how to use those
consolidation areas those how to use the
volume to actually
build up your view and try to guess what
will happen and i just want to show you
something guys i told you i have some
cool things to show so i'm gonna give
you my view on test of course
but before that
look at that let's look at the volume
guys alright so the volume is here it's
the bars that we have here
and what is interesting is to notice
where did we have low volume trading so
look here we have a low volume right
then
you can see we have a low volume trading
i would say you know maybe here
low volume
here low volume
okay
and here low volume here low volume as
well i mean all this area is a very low
volume area right so now we have spotted
that
and here we have a low volume as well
okay so i'm i'm paying attention to the
volume but i compare it to the volume
that we had just before and that into
the volume that we had just after and
you know
i want to see what is happening after we
get out from this low volume areas and
you guys gonna see that this low volume
area is actually where you have those
consolidations so here for example low
volume so i'm just putting a vertical
bar at the beginning of the low volume
period
so here the low volume started here
ended up here
okay
here we have a low volume as well
okay so this one i can take it until
here i mean
we have some ups and downs in the volume
okay if you want i can stop it here then
here the volume starts to increase
slowly
okay
but all this area is low volume area
and here
okay guys let me get rid of that
so what information can we get from that
look guys what is happening so this is
low volume okay
so inside between those vertical bars i
identified where i had a low volume and
then a volume increase and as you can
see
so now i'm gonna
you see show you the same area on the
chart okay guys so those circled areas
are low volume area and after that you
always can draw actually let me remove
that guys
i know that this might seem like a bit
maybe
not easy to understand right now but
look you start from the volume then you
try to find the patterns and you always
have this kind of patterns and this kind
of
resistances support all right
as you can see it can take different
shapes it can take it can be a triangle
it can be a wedge it can be a cap and
handle it can be a head and shoulder you
know all these patterns and always in
these patterns you have at some point a
low volume trading and after the low
volume period is
finished
you
have a breakout and after the breakout
you have a new direction guys okay you
can check at the past breakout here
new direction
downside breakout new direction
then low volume period
breakout new direction so i mean you
know where i'm bringing you guys we have
this we have a double breakout it's a
long term downside breakout guys and
it's a short-term downside breakout of
this pattern after a period of low
volume so
what is this telling you guys this is
telling us that
for now
we are bearish the long-term momentum
has been broken
the only thing that here is not very
clear to me is that the volume increase
so you can see the volume is starting to
pick up here on the way down and then
the huge volume actually occurs on a
green day so this is a little bit
unusual but as long as we are below this
blue trend line that is here guys
so which level is right now at 880
roughly it is not looking good now
what can happen as well if i go on a
weekly chart guys
i'm gonna give you my view i'm gonna
give you what i think will happen and
how to play this move don't worry this
is the reason why i'm doing this video
so here if you go on a weekly chat
because this is a long term move so let
me remove those liquidity areas guys but
once again this is a small tip that you
need to pay attention to whenever you
see a low volume trading
you need to be aware that the next
breakout would probably give you the
direction and here unfortunately it's on
the downside guys
okay so if you are on a weekly chart you
can see we have one breakout and this
week has only started so maybe so the
downside breakout is here
but as you guys know if you have only
one candle it's a breakout but it's not
confirmed if you have a second candle on
the right time frame here the weekly
timeframe is appropriate given a two
years bullish trend that we had then if
the second candle so this week if this
friday guys we are able to close above
this trend line so roughly above 900
then maybe this bearish signal would be
invalidated but for now it is here and
i wouldn't personally be buying at this
levels the levels to buy to me as i'm
saying in my discord guys are between
720 730 and 440 right this area is a
bang area i'm not saying we're going to
get back here but if we do
it's a nice area to buy okay so maybe
average down between those two levels is
a good strategy then the alternative
scenario guys is that we move higher all
right it's possible it's not my
preferred scenario i think we are
bearish here but i will change my
view if i see that the press action
you can see guys we can do this little
game forever guys and this is how
trading is working all right you pay
attention to considerations you pay
attention to volume you pay attention to
breakouts by the way guys you can find
all this information in the course that
i have just released guys three days ago
so you still have 50 percent off guys
until sunday and this course will help
you to understand everything i'm showing
you guys here it will help you to feel
the market you know what i'm doing guys
here is based on analysis of volume
volatility you know those considerations
area and breakout to know whenever the
new direction is found and either you
feel it some traders that just fill the
market or if you don't feel it because
you don't have enough experience on this
market then someone needs to explain it
to you guys and in this course i'm
explaining it so it will help you to you
know really navigate in the market to
feel things to use all these indicators
to enter your trades at the right time
and not fall in some traps all right
guys so get this course it's still 50
discount until uh sunday guys coming
back to tesla here we do the same thing
guys okay
look on the long term we have a downside
record all right but it can be
invalidated we have just seen if before
friday we close above 900 now i go on a
shorter timeframe i go on a daily
timeframe like i was at the beginning
and here you can see guys we have
another trend line
so if
here i see this kind of consideration
happening again and then a breakout this
would be a good signal that actually the
bullish trend is still on
but if i get back to my original
analysis
let me go on the log scale you can see
that it seems we have completed five
waves up right let me remove that
app for to be on a weekly time frame to
check that
so after you have analyzed everything
about the price action so you know
volume uh resistances consideration
areas then you can add on top of that
eliot f theory that is going to help you
to know in which cycle we might be and
here it seems to me that we have
completed this bullish cycle i've always
uh talked about target between 1200 and
you know 1500 so we reached 1200
something so maybe we have completed
this two years bullish cycle and we are
now correcting so if this is the case
the move up lasts two months so we can
expect maybe a six months correction so
i don't know maybe something like this
okay so even with here we move higher
guys if we close above 900 we would
probably go to 1 000 okay so you can
make a short-term bullish trade but the
long-term momentum is to me now broken
and
1000 would be a strong resistance why
1000 first it's a round number second we
have the 20 week moving average coming
here and we have this resistance line
guys just connecting the lows that are
here
and this would be a strong resistance so
even if we go above 900 i don't see a
lot of room on the upside for the coming
month guys so
i think that waiting is the best thing
to do right now uh if the price action
goes below 730
and close to 900 520 it's of course a
very good entry level for long-term
position and yeah that's it i think
there is another strategy but i don't
want to discuss this here guys it's a
bit more complicated it's to buy shares
and sell calls i'm explaining that on my
discord so if you're interested you can
join
and yeah so this is my view guys on
tesla i think we need time i think we're
gonna see some uh maybe ups and downs
maximum to one thousand but then
probably get lower guess i'm afraid we
come back to this area sooner or later
in the coming months and then of course
strong rebound so that's it for me i
hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
you did please don't forget to click on
the sub like and bell button so you're
going to be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
shore i'll see you guys